My name is Abhi and I just completed
the Self-Driving Car Nanodegree program.
For a really long time I've been really
interested in medicine and its
intersection with technology, and that's
kind of always been my motivation to
learn computer science. But after I
actually completed my undergrad
artificial intelligence course, I just
realized I was really interested in a
lot of these problems. The Nanodegree
program actually allowed me to match a
lot of the theory that I learned in
school with implementation. There are
very few places that you're gonna find
where there's so much support to
actually help you grow as an individual
and to help you make the right career move.
The Capstone Project was phenomenal,
predominantly because we actually got to
use ROS. Being able to get exposure to
understanding ROS and all of its
capabilities was really exciting. In
addition to that, our team was
distributed across the globe. We had
someone from Germany, someone from
Singapore, someone from London, from the
East Coast and myself. I think what was
really fun for me was I was definitely
the junior-most individual on the team.
Everyone on the team either had a Master's
or a PhD. But it was great because I had a
huge opportunity to learn from them and
to just be able to bond with them and
understand what their backgrounds were
as well.  It was really cool to just see that
so many people are trying to transition
into this industry after having years
and years of experience in another
industry, and that's a lot of motivation
for myself to be able to surround myself
with some really incredible, talented
engineers as well. There's just so many
different things I would love to work on,
but I think the Nanodegree has really
helped me to realize that a lot of the
things that I imagined as a kid can
start to become reality.